hey
folks happy new year it's the patreon
we're back have you had sex in the new
year uh i have all right
me too
it was a good time pretty pretty
predictable who it was with for both of
us yeah yeah that's true it was with
each other my hand yeah but uh yeah no
man it's uh
it's good to see it's been a minute i
haven't been out that much lately yeah
well you know it's holidays yeah you go
in you go fireplace you go eggnog you go
bearskin rug
yeah
presents gifts made made a couple
boulevardiers at home those are nice
what's in that that's we've had it on
this it's like whiskey campari and
vermouth oh that's good stuff a little
ice put a big i got those big ice cubes
at home i love a big cube yeah i was
doing the noon drinking all holiday yeah
you know i'm with the family so it's
just like
you know you got it there's nothing to
do and they live out in the burbs the
ladies family so you just gotta start
and sauce yeah nice
yeah i mean it's kind of nice to just be
like those days we were like i have
nothing to do i'm gonna get into a new
show i'm gonna have a drink i went on
vacation which i've never i was
literally trying to be like this is what
you do on vacation tonight yeah my
girlfriend she's like are you trying to
explain vacation to me
that thing you've never taken right
she's like and you're trying to break
down what you i'm like i assume this is
gonna be boy
you're just going off [ __ ] you've seen
in movies you're like clark griswold
i guess i'll go saw a tree down
yeah what would you do it you're up in
the the the catskills a lot of moves
near there a lot of movies a lot of uh a
lot of restaurants lots a lot of room
service hey nothing wrong with that it's
weird like
my girlfriend is younger than i am so
she's like never seen she's like what's
a feel-good movie we're just in the
hotel we're watching 22 jump street
it's like a fun movie you know and then
she's like what's a movie like this and
i was like have you ever seen like rush
hour she's like no i'm like [ __ ] she's
just you ever date someone younger than
you and you're like you've never seen
i'm doing it right now yeah yeah and my
gal has never seen any i'm like honey i
short the kids she's like what's that
who got trunk what i'm like ah you're
crazy but then i put it on and she's
just tick-tocking so it's it's useless
yeah but it sucks as you're i'm well
watch the family guy
the family guy i'm old though and we'll
watch family guy and it's just
references all day long of these old
movies and she's not getting any of them
and i'm like you see
you're missing out on fun stuff because
you won't pay attention now i'm turning
into you know a third grade teacher no
you do there is a thing like we do when
we and then you turn to that dude like
why don't we the person who's like you
haven't seen this movie you must watch
this movie then you turn into that
douchebag where you're like just you're
like you're the you're the old guy yes
well you're like hey you haven't seen
dog day afternoon sit down yeah and
they're like ah here's three hours of my
life and then i gotta pretend to like it
it's tough it's i hate when people show
me stuff like hey you gotta see this
book and you're like oh great or like
the house tour you go to the house hey
you gotta have the tour i hate when
people show me [ __ ] yeah and so now i'm
doing it to her and i feel bad but it's
verb in her best interest to see russia
but even that you sound like her dad i
know this is for your own good
i'm gonna spank you but it's you know
it's interesting movies from like the
40s and 50s aren't that tough it's
movies from the 70s that are tough to
show because that's like the cinema of
loneliness period totally we're like
it's like driver taxi driver
the conversation
it's just a dude like fixing a car part
or something and you're like just it's
seven minutes to see you're gonna sit
here and watch deliverance
it's a great tough one that's tough man
respect to ned beatty for taking that
role oh my god the the uh the anal rape
in the woods that was rough how do you
go to any party after that hey ned
yeah
i watched rewatch robocop talk about
dark
yeah i mean that's like i remember
seeing that as a kid and being like wait
how many times did he get shot yes they
shot his hand off and it was uh kurtwood
smith of uh that 70's she loved that guy
great guy the mom from that 70's show is
amazing she is hilarious they're great
actors what's her name she was on
seinfeld too she was she's in like every
sitcom as a bit part killing it but uh
yeah robocop way over the top and i
realize it's a dutch director so those
dutchmen they go crazy they go hard
anyone not in america it's like they're
like they're dark as [ __ ] like
korean movies oh my god korean horror
it's too much yeah i hate that [ __ ]
there she is deborah joe rupp oh she's
awesome she's great
yeah she's in every sitcom ever what uh
there's one called the audition in korea
i think it's it might be japanese
actually but it is i've heard of that
wild like i couldn't get through it
there's a movie i forgot where's it from
it's called feston look it up what what
country's destin yeah it's like a family
reunion
uh and you find out basically some real
dark [ __ ] has happened in the family
mm-hmm
i think it's called it's like translates
to a celebration yeah the celebration is
this scandinavian because they go nuts
too i don't what is that
i don't want to sound super ignorant
here
you ever say danish all right oh dana
yeah see the dutch they judge me they go
hard they go hard i mean you ever heard
of like uh finnish or uh icelandic rock
the heavy metal out there it's wild they
make marilyn manson look like uh raffy
it's hard to do that after the
allegations
but they manage that's true uh yeah so
what did what you just got drunk for the
most of the uh
pretty drunk did a puzzle just die
oh yeah that's when you know things are
uh there's a low bar
but uh did uh did the lego seinfeld set
yeah yeah we got to do the gifts on here
oh that'd be great yeah we should open
those i brought yours back really yeah
they're here i brought them all the way
to my house then i brought them back six
months later yeah
oh [ __ ] we got to open it should we open
them on the patreon yeah as well forget
all this we're unboxing is it here
no no these are gifts from the fans
i can't hear you man
uh left oh oh here oh there you go
should i open these yeah i'll start
opening these all right
gotta keep my eye on the phone we got a
big guest coming folks
all right here we go
unboxing
thanks to everybody at home for sending
stuff in
all right pee betty white
oh dude and uh [ __ ] a lot of feelings a
lot of people have john madden
did you know john madden created the
like when people do the x and o's on the
screen whoa
i did not know that isn't that crazy
that's wild that guy was a legend man i
loved i love john madden legend scared
of flying
yeah that's weird yeah he also retired
from coaching at like 42 and in the hall
of fame which is insane can you imagine
being done like imagine being done from
comedy at 42. that's insane because also
it's like coaching is another thing
where usually you don't break
i think i heard somewhere it's like bill
parcells is the other like one of the
greatest coaches ever
he didn't start coaching until 42. oh
wow
it's like rodney he didn't start till 50
or get famous till 50.
oh this is dope
[Music]